do the game that was the most fun which
is weird was the mario kart now the bad
part is that's not going to come out to
like 2014 but dude the game the graphics
are polished the game is awesome you get
to glide in the air with your cart I was
just I was tripping out of that and
another good one was a black light which
is already on for the ps3 but they was
shown it for the ps4 and I was fun to
play and they had this yeah there's
other one word I forgot the name of Adam
and your man and your squid and you got
these weird tentacles and you have to
move the tentacles with the joystick
that's for the ps4 and that was pretty
fun games that I'm excited about killer
instinct is a must infinity or know what
what's it called guessing [ __ ] up
sorry destiny watch dogs watch dogs I
wanna play that remind me a hott Dogg so
hott Dogg hott Dogg I haven't played
them but destiny and call of duty ghosts
that just incredible especially destiny
I was like a 10 year plan which is
incredible I can't wait to see what
Bungie doesn't that because they'd halo
now they go to destiny it's going to be
really really awesome I wanted to play
some part of the batman game and I guess
either it's not ready or they want you
gotta have a special ticket to get in
now try to sneak in and they call
security it's weird like there's another
game that i really like called Lost
Planet I know a lot of people don't
don't like the game because it's kind of
glitchy well used to be back in that
kind of day but I wanted to play that
there was a lot of people in line for
that I really stuck with xbox but then I
actually got a hands-on with the
controllers cuz i'm an xbox guy with the
xbox 360 controller but they Microsoft
decided to change the controller and
it's two different I don't know maybe I
can play more games but I really really
do like the PlayStation 4 can
it fits in your hand really nicely and
it's just perfect yeah game and blew me
away man smash brothers wii u that's all
I want honestly that's all I'm worried
about we got mega man coming through we
have the wii fit trainer the villager
all these new characters and I love
smash brothers so there's that and halo
bot yeah those are my top 30 kingdom
hearts oh forgot about keyboard my bad
yo kingdom hearts sorry I'm [ __ ] us
alright kingdom hearts 3 smash brothers
killer instinct halo 5 top before I
think those for the Xbox has twitchtv
built into it so you can be playing a
game and recording it all live streaming
it at the same time the PlayStation is
Ustream butt twitches like the major
gaming platform live streaming so it's
going to be interesting to see how that
all plays out Microsoft it's not that
they don't have a good machine because
I'm still going to get it because I like
an entertainment box but Microsoft
really made the mistake in a PR war you
know basically saying hey if you're all
flying to just give to 360 you know
enough screw you and you know they even
though they didn't say it like that that
was the message message that kind of
feel too will turn people off some I'm
hoping they clean up their message it's
a good console but so far Sony is
killing it is packed and that Sony event
every time I go over there I guess since
I make videos with games i have to pick
both because i'll need them both but
definitely playstation want it but i
don't know if i'm picking a side yet I
think Nintendo won the console war with
me honestly because I'm not a fan of the
whole 599 399 drm you can't borrow games
you can borrow games here look how we
borrow and nah man i got a wii u already
you know smash brothers coming up that's
all I needed to hear honestly and we
don't have like a release date for halo
5 like when halo pockets release date I
might change my mind or if like destiny
is killing over on PlayStation even
though it's on a few systems I don't
know it's Nintendo right now Nintendo
kiltie they got the new mario they got
the new smash
they got Donkey Kong they got Mario Kart
I need is mario party i'm done i could
go to other ones away accidentally i'm
so off the waste that money go spend it
on like strippers
by travelpod member
you
you
you